yes Christopher Hitchens joins us this
morning and we're here to talk with him
about his views about Iraq well you're
talking to us on a week of course when
the constitutional process is delayed
but this morning the AP ran a story of
some encouragement that they think that
they're going to break through and reach
compromises and also the day after some
horrific bombings again in the country
what's your feeling about where all this
stands right now the policy I haven't
seen the AP report I'm pleased to hear
about it but I know that your examples
you give both essentially accurate and
they couldn't quite a bit of contrast in
one case the Iraqis are trying to create
noticed a federal system that satisfies
the needs of the different ethnic and
communal functions but also a democratic
favoritism extraordinary thing even to
be trying in that area and on the other
side you have the most savage Islamist
nihilism you largely but not exclusively
efficient by foreigners in their country
who would rather see a rope bleed to
death
and to see this experiment succeed so I
think it's as simple as that and one has
to keep on asking people but as politely
as possible which side are they on and
I've chosen mine and I hope you can
guess which one it is in fact a column
that you wrote earlier this month you
there was one line that caught my
attention which says that supporters of
the of the war paraphrasing must come to
grips with the possibility of failure of
defeat yes and I think there's a
tendency in argument for people to line
up like this those of us who think the
regime change in Iran was necessary
stressing the good news and those who
don't like it or don't either President
or don't think you told the truth
stressing the bad in fact I think it
should be the other way around because
the possibility of defeat is such an
awful one you have to imagine the sort
of people who'd be running Iraq a
country of that size and importance
where we've made so many promises taken
over by bin Laden ISM we should we
should be looking down that gun barrel
all the time and realizing what the
stakes are
now what do you
make of the what seems to be rising
anti-war sentiment in this country
epitomized most visibly by Cindy Sheehan
and the hundreds or thousands of
supporters in demonstrations all around
the country last night also by new poll
that I have here from reported in the
Washington Times this morning that
suggests I probably can't reach it the
president's approval rating is down to
forty three percent and a front-page
story in The New York Times bad Iraq war
news has some and GOP worried over the
midterm elections well in order for
those three I mean I think that the
anti-war forces have made a mistake by
adopting this some Sheehan woman and
letting her become their spokesman she's
some not just a grieving mother this is
not just a sort of soft centered August
human interest sob story I mean I
published in Slate a couple of days ago
what her real political opinions are by
the way I must say for my own profession
I think it's scandalous that this was
not done before she's written a long
screed in which she says that her son
was killed in a war organized by jewish
kaballa see for jewish government in the
united states you knew he was he died
died was murdered for israel and she
said open me that she thinks there's a
root cause of terrorism in the world as
the president of the united states well
I think that's a disgraceful position
and I think it should have been she
should be called on it before I called
her on it and when she was finally asked
where she lied and said she hadn't made
this statement so she's a hysterical
fabricator in two ways what one she's
come up with this wild confection of
partly moveon.org currently david duke
opinions but both of these forces by the
way have come out and supported her and
ii she's not been honest enough to admit
that those are her opinions so I think
it'll be over quite soon the same thing
I think should be exposed as a fraud and
I think those who've tried to make a
emotional martyr moral blackmail out if
it will regret it anyway they should be
made to regret it and the profession of
great profession of journalism should
stop being a megaphone for such a person
and just handing her the mic and saying
just say what you
we have no questions and on domestic
politics well I sometimes put it like
this if the President and the US
administration were good at making their
case about Iraq you know I could take a
lot of time off I mean the things are so
bad that you know I have to come on and
try and explain what I think it's worth
fighting for I think they've done a
generally very bad job of doing so and
that's partly because there's a great
split within the administration about
this I mean if the administration makes
a claim it might be incorrect one say
about the connection between Saddam
Hussein and bin Laden ISM bar fishermen
bin Laden ISM someone from the CIA will
tell the New York Times you know and to
be on the front page you know we don't
think that's true so that the whole case
gets undermined by a division within me
within the government they've almost
given up in fact trying to make the case
oh all the bush can think of to say is
just to say well we have to stay the
course and though I agree with him about
that and I've never heard anyone make a
persuasive argument that we should
abandon around it suffers from
diminishing returns and many Republicans
were not in favor of this really to
begin with they could have done without
this
indeed we Bush himself was alleged on a
program of lifting the sanction the
first time lifting the sanctions on Iran
not using American troops for
nation-building or humanitarian purposes
in some ways a lot of the right-wing
don't have the stomach for doing this
phone lines are right beneath me on the
screen here in Washington for our radio
viewers two zero two seven three seven
triple zero one if you support the
president's policy in Iraq if you
support the Democrats two zero two seven
three seven triple zero two and our line
for independence two zero two six two
eight zero two zero five as you know we
called you specifically this morning
because yesterday we had Harold Marston
on Washington Post columnist and also
the editor of American Prospect and you
are depicted I don't which think of
their characterization of you on the
time that you see the photograph I read
the article well fortunately the viewers
can judge for themselves perhaps a
little a little more hug like than I
actually are they didn't get the beard
but he
I only grew that in Iran recently to try
to make myself less conspicuous with
Charles Krauthammer
Bill Kristol and Tom Friedman as pundits
who are responsible for what he sees as
a failed policy he named you spoke about
you and I we want you'd have a chance to
respond to his criticism here's one of
the comments he made yesterday he has
looked at the war through a lens of
actually his long associations with some
Kurd Kurdish insurgents against Saddam
Hussein's regime and some of the secular
some of the secular left in Iraq and I
think rightly he is identified with them
and has seen this as a contest between
them and Saddam Hussein and so he took
sides and once he took sides that was it
the practical consequences of of the
intervention where we're sort of beside
the point and he did something as well
which some some folks coming out of a
Marxist background do which is said
clearly history is on these folks side
they are the force of the future well I
must say that's a very a fairly decent
summary of my position rather fair
minded as is his article there's an
attempt to be sarcastic about it but
it's quite true my position derives
originally from solidarity with the
Iraqi opposition to Saddam Hussein the
Arab and Kurdish opposition who I
thought had the germs of a democratic
future in them in any case we should be
on their side win or lose having in the
past let them down
I do think yes that they as for saying
histories on any one side one should be
careful but I think the United States is
on the right side of history in the
region now after being on the wrong side
several times in there is a definite
evolution towards democratic pluralism
you can feel it you can see it in
Lebanon you can see it in Egypt are the
people who taking part in these
movements so said to me that it was
greatly helped great afforded by the
that I was saying by kicking out of from
the rulership of a Keystone state in the
region the psychopathic fascist state
crime family
mr. Marcin is entitled his view that I
therefore think that none of the actual
consequences are relevant that's
obviously not true but I view them
through that prism sure yes I do and in
fact I feel flattered that he's noticed
that's motive those who say we should
abandon the Iraqi and Kurdish Democrats
and give over the country to bin Laden
ISM and Balthus and the chaos by arson
rights of you and the others he names
that they subordinated the facts on the
ground to their own ideological
preferences and those are their allies
within the administration refused to
hold the administration's conduct of the
war and the occupation to the ideals
that they themselves professed or simply
to the standard of common-sense
abdicated their responsibilities as
political intellectuals and more
reliable 'mentally as reliable
empiricists they were wrong
colossal e wrong about the single most
important matter that can be put before
the American public indeed they were
more than wrong they ceased being
intellectuals and became apologists with
that with respect that appears to
contradict what he just saw him say on
the screen about my views and my motives
and I I don't know to what you're
referring there which is this most
important decision or what facts on the
ground if I ignored does he specify
anyone any such thing things it says
here things are in fact going well the
insurgency is dying Abu Ghraib is not a
scandal
Saddam Hussein did have ties to al-qaeda
you just don't know it yet and so on
well to take those in order oh there's
nothing minor about the Abu Drive
scandal but the drivers a lot better off
nonetheless than it was three years ago
when it was a concentration camp and and
a slaughterhouse and I think one just I
will only argue seriously with someone
who acknowledges that that is true
I think most people hadn't heard of our
crime until recently I will grave until
recently there's with there's an entire
connection between Saddam and I don't
it's now been made material and opened
for all to see mr sarkar we the leader
of the so-called insurgents there's not
even in Iraqi names his group al-qaeda
in Mesopotamia has sought and received
bin Laden's blessing for this now mr.
Sirko he was in Iraq before this began
operating against my Kurdish comrades
among other things and there was a very
clear connection then between his group
and the Saddam secret police people who
don't see this don't see it but they
shouldn't try and be sarcastic with me
about excite hey I know what I'm talking
about
and be I'm willing to look these facts
in the face the naive people are those
who think that the confrontation in Iraq
could have been avoided that we could
have just watched to see what might
happen as Saddam went more and more
crazy and as his lunatic sons either
took power together or had a war between
each other as to which of them it would
be that would have been lovely to watch
we'd have had to intervene later on much
more much less advantageous terms so as
I say the the naivety and self-deception
comes from people who maintain still
that's what I was saying was really no
problem one could not be more naive and
deceptive than that to some calls for
you beginning with jacksonville florida
you're on the air yes thank you for
letting me on the air mr. Hitchens and
my fan of yours
thank you mom I got a subscription to
Rolling Stone and I tell you if you ever
left the magazine I would cancel my
subscription so never written for an
instant but you surely Schiedam vision
okay I had two questions about articles
that you wrote one was about the Michael
Moore movie and one about the Ohio
election okay the first one about the
Michael Moore movie is that when you
wrote that article criticizing his movie
you went on a program I think it was
seen on and you had a co-panelists I
think his name was Tom tour main you
know he wrote for Rolling Stone magazine
that's who I was referring to I don't
know he's an african-american member his
name okay the question okay but
he had made a comment that the movie
that affected the part of the movie that
affected him the most was the part where
a woman's home was destroyed by the
American army and that he cried I wasn't
I wonder if he was aware that during the
Civil War President Lincoln and General
Grant authorized that entire cities be
burnt to the ground in the south and I
also wonder if somebody made a movie in
the Civil War in which they showed the
destruction that the Union Army caused
in the south but didn't show anything
about slavery and people like Spike Lee
would not be offended by a movie like
that and I suspect they would be thank
you very much it doesn't need a call for
any comment from me I mean except yes I
absolutely see your point I'm not even
sure that the film did really show the
u.s. army destroying anyone same as they
should
a night rage of some soldiers entering
the house but none of the clips in that
film can be trusted Livonia Michigan
you're next Chris for Hitchin go ahead
please good morning thank you you know
President Bush says that we're fighting
these terrorists because they don't like
our lifestyle which may be true but you
know I think myself the president's
policies in this country I would have to
him include him with the list of people
that don't like our lifestyles the way
he's a attacking social security and
overtime pay all the things that are
traditionally good for our country and
so you know and he says you're with us
or against us but I'd like to know who
would President Bush would because I
don't feel like he's with me
and I'm sorry mr. Hitchens you know I
wish you'd realize a lot of people in my
position don't get a voice and thank God
for Cindy Sheehan thank you no well I
quite a number of things in particular I
don't like his piety his religiosity at
all his recent absurd statements about
in the non theory that calls itself
intelligent design
would be a case in point I don't think
he said lifestyle by the way and I don't
think that the forces of al-qaeda are
interested particularly in overtime pay
or social situation either what I think
he meant to say was way of life or
civilization and on that point the main
point he's right this is an attack on
the very idea of liberal floral ISM and
secure ISM on which our republic is
based and it is a deadly I mean it's
good to be able to know an enemy when
you see one now the president seems to
get this point in a way that a lot of
liberals do not so until that question
is cleared up I don't think you can you
entitled to introduce any any old
distraction and say well just because of
that I don't agree with him on the war
you have to have let me know what you
think about the first case which you
didn't though I suppose I can guess
because if you fancy miss Sheehan and
her antics I'm presuming that you
sympathize with her and saying that this
war is fought for Israel and is run by a
secret cabal within the administration
and that miss bender the president the
United States is the most significant
terrorists in the world if that is your
view you would've have the courage to
say sir
New Orleans good morning good morning
yes I'm 100% against the war and I don't
agree with mr. Hitchens position at all
I think this war is totally 100 percent
neocolonialism is wasting billions of
dollars that could be used for a lot of
domestic purposes and it's very very
funny that uh a lot of people say that
we're fighting terrorism but if you look
outside the window you don't see any
other troops anywhere in the United
States anywhere near the United States
but if the Iraqis look out to wonder if
a lot of other people in different parts
of the world look out the window they
have United States troops and planes
bombs and and ships surrounding their
country so who's really being threatened
I have never felt threatened by any
terrorist and particularly as they as an
African American I feel like this whole
fitting over the idea of democracy is
not legitimate because under the guise
of democracy in this particular country
we were made slaves for over eighty
seven years of its particular existence
had to mention the colonial existence
under the British Empire and then the de
facto factor of being disenfranchised
for another hundred years under the
whole name of democracy if you ask most
white people when our this country
became a democracy they would say from
the beginning so how can you say
democracy is such a superior form of
government when this country and other
people in the world realized this and
they also realized that the Western
powers particularly Britain and then
later the United States are responsible
for much of the claw realism and the neo
colonialism around the world so thank
you let's stop there yes I got his drift
well actually he gives him he gives me a
chance with your permission to waive my
new book will find bookstores everywhere
and does have quite a long discussion
about the moment at which of the
founding of the Republic
mr. Jefferson tried to write into the
Declaration a denunciation of slavery
and I've reprinted what he actually said
what that would have said if it had been
in and I give the reasons which you can
I'm sure sir guess why it was struck out
I mean largely to placate the southern
colonies states to be Georgia and the
Carolinas but also the slave traders
rather than slaveholders in New York and
I go I go on at some length about what
things were like on mr. Jefferson's
plantation as well so believe me you're
not talking to someone who would have
given that naive reply if you'd ask me
the question um for the rest of what you
said it seems to me it would be true
that's to say the prolongation of
slavery and disenfranchisement would be
true whatever our policy was in Iraq I
mean would have been true would remain
as true as historically as you say it is
but it
it didn't seem to me that you made any
real connection between that in our
policy in Mesopotamia now and do bear in
mind that a lot of the people who oppose
the war like mr. David Duke and mr. Pat
Buchanan's so are members of the extreme
right and not known for their sympathy
for civil rights or the rights of
minorities in this country so I'm feared
I'm afraid we probably disagree
essentially on what the grammar of this
argument should be Springfield South
Carolina supporting the president
pleasure to speak with you I spoke with
you a number of years ago on Slee
spending and we have slight disagreement
about religion I know your this case for
religion but I would like to commend you
of light you are one of the most clear
speaking and logical people on this
subject that I have had the pleasure to
listen to you know on any venue and I
applaud your move to common sense and
logic which might even be called to move
somewhat to the right but I'd like you
also to address this point and we've
heard it by the man who just called
making what sob refer to in public
you've heard referred to before as the
dirty hands argument and that is as
follows because we at some point in our
past have been something that was less
than stellar as all nations of course
around the world have done some much
much work than we have done that we're
now not entitled to try to do the right
thing in the cases where we can for them
he was a bringing up slavery they make
the argument the Liberals are so fond of
making the argument that the the fact
that we use at some point in the past
made a mistake at some point in the past
as you yourself well illustrate with
Henry Kissinger
do things that didn't make sense or
maybe working a good idea that now we
are forever damned and can never do
something right that's one point with
the Liberals and the second point is
could you also address the way the
liberals can't have a reasoned logical
discussion about this as you are trying
to do but carry it to such extremes of
war IPEDS events compared to Nazi then
where do you hear
purely as I'm thrown around when in fact
if we were in fact the Nazis or we were
Imperial Rome or even British Empire as
you well know we would never leave a
country once we deplete congregate or
taking it over in fact we'd now occupy
most of Europe we dock you pop most of
Japan thanks I'm gonna jump in we
understand the point no fair enough I
mean I did write a book about Henry
Kissinger and his foreign policy career
if you concurred that that says that he
should be charged and if charge would be
convicted of war crimes and crimes
against humanity and I could probably
tell quite a number of liberals and
people on the left things that they
don't know about crimes committed by the
United States in the past which would
include kissing was betrayal of the
Kurds who he supported as the Rope
supports the hanging man in the 1970s
promised them support made them risk
their lives in an uprising against
Saddam Hussein and cut them off abruptly
without telling him he was going to
leaving them to die on the hillsides the
one would also have to include the
period where mr. Rumsfeld was going to
Iraq and shaking Saddam Hussein's hand
ostensibly because we preferred him to
the ayatollah khomeini which there might
have been a case for doing but after
that war with iran was over continuing
to give him the sinews of war letting
him use them for genocide or purposes
within the borders of Iraq itself so it
seems to me that these past crimes and
blunders redouble our responsibilities
redouble our responsibilities to put
that right and to accept our
responsibility to the people of Iraq and
to the into the country not try and
dodge that and and so to speak make good
on it this time it would be my case
would in fact if you like therefore be
weaker if it wasn't true that our policy
in the past has been so ill founded and
misjudged I'm sorry I've just remembered
something that the gentleman before you
said The Gentle from from New Orleans I
think he said I wrote it down he said I
have never been threatened by any
terrorist I don't know I can't quite
think what he means by that does he mean
New Orleans hasn't been
yet I live a long way from New York and
Washington so it doesn't affect me I
don't know I just wish I had him back on
the line now but I hope that it was
noticed by others that that's what he
said that seems to be a very parochial
and provincial and narrow view of the
matter to me just because he hasn't been
hurt by it does not mean it's not a
problem
Detroit good morning yes first of all
and I'd like to say that mr. Hitchens
because you are such a talented and
intelligent individual I believe that
you are amongst the most vile of
propagandists for this and apologist for
this Bush administration because I
somehow get the feeling that you know
that what a lot of what you're saying is
very much a lie I believe as someone who
has followed the war from the very
beginning that you know that there was
absolutely no need to rush into this war
simply because of the sanctions that we
had placed on Saddam Hussein the no-fly
zones that we had on him and the weapons
inspections regime that we had on this
man people can say that he kicked them
out but he lets him back in and Bush
pulls him out I believe that you know
that much of what you're saying is in
fact confusing the American people the
right-wing base of the bush crowd you
you as a human being abandoned your
family just like Rush Limbaugh as a drug
addict you are one of those vilest of
republican right-wing scumbags who
simply does not serve this country well
I'm gonna stop you right there as it
gets ad hominem well do ad hominem would
mean would mean that what he was saying
about me even if personal was true
issues
it will have a pull guy I mean I think
this that's probably made his day and I
think he may be the sort of person whose
day is made by that kind of thing I mean
of course what's heard the arguments
before the Saddam Hussein was in a box
with sanctions and inspections in their
fly zones and it would be nice in a way
if that were true but as we now know the
these sanctions were turning into a
racket and oil-for-food racket in which
those who were supposed to be
distinguishing between the Iraqi
civilian population and its needs of the
needs of the regime Aslam were trading
openly and cynically with the regime and
in fighting their own pockets and it was
an oil for palaces programming and oil
for corruption program in the no-fly
zones were very good idea but all they
could do was prevent the renewal of
genocide and when you say that we rushed
into the war most people I think would
would agree with me at least that the
root cause of this of current argument
the origins current is whether or not it
was correct to leave Saddam Hussein in
power in 1991 I'm one of those who
thought that the Bush administration was
wrong to confirm him in power there
which means that this arguments been
going on for more than a decade I don't
know how much of a rush you call that
Harold Marston in his article that you
just cited refers to erupted twice I
think as a war of choice as he no what's
he says I'm wrong in saying that
confrontation was inevitable I simply
didn't understand how people can can
convince themselves that another
confrontation with Saddam Hussein was
not inevitable and in our future but
just on the term war of choice I thought
it's rather suggestive because if if I'm
right and there is a blatant
contradiction confrontation coming
if we don't indeed choose the time of it
then what we're saying is will let him
choose the time and the place which we
always had up till that he'd always been
allowed to surprise us invade Iran
invade Kuwait used chemical weapons in
the north of his country not his country
the north of Iran mr. Martin appears to
be saying since we often say no we'll
stop this will put an end to this regime
now
we chose to do it that's that's in some
way a wicked decision well if that
leaves him with the responsibility of
saying well let's not choose it then
let's him
let's let Saddam choose so that is
really your counsel of despair and I
think of masochism and almost suicide
how important is the trial of Saddam
Hussein and the most very important it's
it's very potent I wish it had already
begun being a lot of experiments and
misunderstandings about it but I think
that the it's essential that people who
commit acts of the sort that he
committed or his life be brought to
justice in front of their own people if
we can't get them to an international
tribunal is much better if they can be
tried in their own countries I would
instance the case of Pinochet in Chile
it was very important he was finally
indicted by a Chilean court that he'd
been wanted by other other courts and
prosecutors in Europe very important of
the Argentine generals the same General
General Videla particularly were tried
and jailed in Argentina it's a pity we
couldn't have puts a slow time law
switch on trial in Belgrade but his
trial is covered regularly live on TV
and people in Serbia from Washington
they used to admire him when he started
off sort of bluffing and strutting and
now he's been just worn down by months
and months now years of the presentation
of more and more solid evidence and the
grin has been wiped off his face and
it's been a tremendous education for the
people of former Yugoslavia and so I
can't wait for this childhood again and
wow I have one trivial reason I can't
wait for the evidence to be presented as
I've seen some of it I know what its
gonna look like
it will stop people saying to me okay I
agree that I was saying was a bad guy
that's always the dead giveaway
statement Luis shows you're talking to
someone who has no idea if they had the
faintest idea of the sorts of things
that he was responsible for they
wouldn't be contend with saying okay
he's a bad guy you're dealing really
with the face of evil here with the
regime that was run by professional
sadists and whether were the Psychopaths
were in
the asylum the wounds in Iraq are so
deep in cigar States and Hornets and
it's so little understood that I'm
really impatient to see justice being
done and very proud very proud o to be a
supporter of the policy that put him in
that jail and will put him in that dog
houston good morning you're on the air
hi I'm so glad to be able to talk to you
I'm really very nervous but I'd like to
know have you ever read the book by
janae Davis called the third terrorists
the foreword is written by David
shippers who successfully prosecuted the
impeachment case against Clinton in the
House of Representatives she names names
talks about the front companies and also
this I witness 'as some of them of all
of them of course they're Oklahoma City
residents and I don't know why none of
them have never called in have you ever
read the book
no and I didn't know so we've just made
it clear that what the book was about
it's about mr. McVeigh you are
absolutely correct about Saddam Hussein
according to this book you need to read
it mr. Hitchens it will make you more
resolved about your opinions today
school desert terrorist terrorist by
janae Davis she was and just an NBC
affiliate reporter working for the
embassy affiliate and I you know David
shippers it was a former federal career
prosecutor yes I know I know I know
about mr. Schiller's very well well he
wrote the forward to the book America
needs to read this they need to know
about it they need to dispel the lies
had been told over and over about the
president his motives why we went to war
in Iraq I can't believe after 9/11 that
Saddam Hussein wasn't the first person
they thought of and may I ask you in the
book who does she start who does she
make the case for as the 3rd terrace she
was names different said uh his name is
second say me and I read I gave the book
to my aunt she read it my brother
many people as I can tell about this
book please America go out and read it
buy it and read it
thank you
yeah I think maybe there is i I'm
guessing but what the thesis of the book
would be so I shouldn't comment on that
but there was the risk there still is a
man named I've just forgotten his first
name mr. Yasiin anyway is his name and
he was the man who mixed the chemicals
for the attempt to blow up the World
Trade Center in 1993 where the plan was
submitted to collapse one tower make it
fall into another one he mixed the
explosive for this was caught
apprehended by the FBI incredibly given
bail because he was a cooperative
witness after admitting timing done is
to skip straight to Iraq which is the
country it's not that easy to get into
by the way or out offered that wasn't at
that point it can't just go but was lazy
and it was sheltered by Saddam Hussein
ever afterwards the most wanted man in
the World Trade Center case and you
still hear people saying was no there's
no connection between Saddam and the the
Muslim jihadist terrorists I mean in the
face of the plain evidence that that it
was a very warm and tender relationship
mr. Yasiin is still at large by the way
it was thought he might be captured
during the intervention but he just got
away but he's still got a big price on
his head
Torrance California good morning good
morning I have a question and an answer
the question is why is the USA losing
the PR bail against a murders
psychopathic lunatic who is in a cave
and my answer has to do with the fact
that we humans think in terms of
metaphors or frames the metaphor that we
have Americans principally of occupation
is a benign one the occupation of Japan
and Germany the the metaphor that Middle
Easterners have of occupation is that of
Israel occupying Palestine David comment
please
well yes occupation is supposed to be
neutral as a term it's a legal term
actually but obviously it's acquired
different connotations in different ears
just to say the word collaboration now
doesn't mean quite what it used to mean
before the second world all it means
there's someone with him you cooperate
but you know it it sounds different if
you take the two examples you you just
offered me the Israel doesn't in a sense
occupy the West Bank it claims the West
Bank I mean there were some of its
ideologues do they say this is already
Israeli Church it was it's mandated for
us by God slightly different proposition
from saying we will have to send troops
to garrison Japan for a while until the
country is rebuilt and then we'll leave
I think technically now the our presence
in Iraq is not defined any longer by the
UN or any other international body as an
occupation because it's given way to a
general cracking the election
constitutional government which has Pro
Tam invited the United States to and
Britain all the members of the
Commission to keep their forces there so
that they're there in theory but the
request of the Iraqi government and it's
a sure thing the United States doesn't
want to owe in Iraq and nor does it say
that God gave us its territory so
identified helps to resolve any of the
of the linguistic confusion Anderson
Texas good morning ring good morning mr.
Hitchens good morning I really enjoyed
your your earlier work mr. Hitchens but
um I've kind of observed your writing
and see I believe really that you tried
to get ahead of the curve in some
respects especially in regards to some
of your work on people like dr.
Kissinger for instance and you know you
you're kind of affiliated now with the
group of what we might refer to as Odd
Fellows for yourself you know many of
the former the former Nixon team for
instance Rumsfeld etc I saw the thing on
the History Channel where they were
showing corpse of rums ville speaking in
his former capacity as a spokesman for
the Nixon war machine in Vietnam and his
kind
the evasive arrogant remarks were
word-for-word with the little game that
he's spouting right now which I'm sure
he would be amused about but what I was
speaking towards were the fact that in
all of these nations that you refer to
and I wanted to point out Pakistan and
the fact that you know it turned out
after all of this that the greatest
danger of all was coming from and a
Pakistani nuclear scientist who was
indeed spreading a nuclear death and and
and doomsday through the world he was a
Pakistani but my point is that in all
these nations you have a fanatical a
group of right-wing even in Israel who
will do anything to hold power including
destroying their own country and
assassinating their own leaders I have
to jump in we're almost out of time well
I'm not quite sure which thread to pull
on there but if I may I'll select them
the instance you gave of mr. AQ Khan you
didn't name him but that's who you must
have meant I think who was a Pakistani
nuclear scientist father of as they say
of the Pakistani nuclear project who'd
gone into business as a kind of nukes
are us Walmart dealing in the technology
and access to with North Korea with
Libya and potentially with other
countries too and perhaps with Iran I
would just want to point out to use and
to anyone else who's watching that we
only know about mr. AQ Khan for this
reason Colonel Gaddafi capitulated not
long ago went to Tony Blair and George
Bush and said I give up I'm going to
stop trying to build myself a nuclear
weapon it's too expensive the game isn't
worth the candle I've been basically
found out and and because of what he'd
seen happen in Iraq and all the fissile
material or chance to shape it all that
all the extraordinary arsenal that was
disclosed by him underground facilities
in the Libyan desert is now under lock
and key in Oak Ridge Tennessee which I
hope you'll agree is a better place for
it to be now that's a huge step forward
for anti-nuclear proliferation problem
and it did when we walked back the cat
from that evidence identify the aq car
network and help us shut it down I
maintained that a lot of the credit for
that breakthrough goes to the decision
to remove Saddam Hussein from power to
break the logjam in the region because
it's there were other pressures on mr.
Gaddafi to give up his own WMD program
but when he did decide to do so he
didn't go to the UN didn't go to Kofi
Annan it didn't go to Jacques Chirac of
the EU he came straight to bush and
Blair and said I'm giving up I'm handing
over don't tell me that that isn't a
vindication of the policy of confronting
dictators who cheat on weapons
inspections we're out of time but always
appreciate you coming to talk to our
audience Christopher Hitchens as we've
said writes for Vanity Fair and he also
posts a blog on Slate comm but you can
find out where to find him on his own
website Hitchens web.com
and we'll remind you again that he has a
book on a very different subject the
biography of Thomas Jefferson it's part
of the eminent live series of Atlas
Books HarperCollins and it is widely
available in the bookstore of your
choice
thank you for being here throwing thanks
last segment of the morning is on a very
different topic and that is on the
rising use of methamphetamine in the
United States this afternoon at 3
o'clock we're going to show you a
congressional hearing that has to do
with this we're going to show you a
little bit of that in the break and when
we come back Larry nake who is the
executive director of the National
Association of counties which has been
very involved in the collection of data
and formulation of policy on the use of
meth in the US will be here to talk to
you about it this is actually the ninth
hearing focusing on